most of you are probably aware that on
freecodcamp.org
we have a comprehensive and interactive
curriculum to help you learn full stack
web development well we're constantly
adding new certifications and our new
web3 curriculum is ready for you to try
it's still in development but we now
have five integrated projects ready for
you to complete
in this video you will watch free code
camp team members sean and tom complete
the projects
so get ready to learn more about web3
and see if you can follow along with
sean and tom as they work through the
projects
welcome free code camp this is the web 3
curriculum tom and i are running through
the integrated projects that we have
ready
and
in front of us we have the article that
shows you how to run the free code camp
uh web3 curriculum in your local vs code
setup
it walks you through
what projects are available as
well as how you can run the course
once more projects are ready you will be
able to sign up for updates
and
just listen to your emails because once
we start releasing
you'll get updates on those
so
to get started we can head to our
terminal
and we just need to
get clone the repo which is in
github at free code camp
web three curriculum
yeah it mentions in the instructions
there um
kind of specifically what to do i think
so there's a few prerequisites obviously
uh vs code
and then
uh docker is the main one i guess
because this all runs in docker so
you have to install those two things for
sure
and then once you get those few
prerequisites installed in the article
then you can i guess just clone the repo
and run it or something like that
we'll share we'll share a link to the
instructions
to get it set up in the description
there so
and once we make sure that we have
docker running
we can add vs code open up command
palette and say remote containers
rebuild and reopen in container
now this usually does take a while but
what i like to do
is either go make myself something to
drink or just watch
the terminal
as it builds
okay is that it ready
yeah i think um
this is what i typically see when it's
ready is that the last thing it installs
that last extension there
okay awesome so now we can use the
free code
camp extension
to
[Music]
run the course
first we'll prep the course
and you can see what it's doing if you
head into the terminal
labeled free code cam run course
but you really don't need to worry about
what's in there
so
let us
again you are introduced with the
landing page which describes the course
there will be a link to frequently asked
questions just in case you get stuck or
are confused with how to start
as you can see there are quite a few
projects that we have coming soon here
currently the projects that are ready
are what we are calling the integrated
projects
the integrated projects are like
certification projects on the
free codecam forward slash learn
platform in that
you don't learn anything
through the course
you are prepared through practice
projects
you get taught the content that you need
in order to complete the integrated
project so the integration project just
has a bunch of user stories that you are
expected to
complete in order to go through this
all right i got this loaded up and what
i'm going to try and do is go through
this first available project
it's called build a video game
marketplace blockchain um so you click
on it and you come to the instructions
here
and then it gives you the files there
okay
so i guess we're gonna create a
blockchain for video game marketplace
uh where we can buy and sell items and
we're gonna work within this folder
so i'm gonna just go in there to start
and
um
okay it says json files will store
information about your blockchain um
there are functions in blockchain
helpers for reading and writing to them
you'll need to look at those to see what
arguments they need and what they do
they're already included in the files
where you need them
um the items you can buy or sell are in
items.json
so
we've got this items.js and i can buy
some stuff there
many of the files are finished for you
you only need to add code in
this handful of files
and run terminal commands and finish all
the user stories and pass the tests
okay so
your blockchain will be stored in
blockchain.json
you can initialize by running node init
blockchain um
okay there's there's just a bunch of
users here that'll explain to you what
to do
um
no generate wallets so we can create
some wallets
yeah
mining
blocks hashes oh geez there's a lot of
stuff here
um
so
these these this blockchain.json is
going to hold our blockchain and then we
already looked at items um
transactions is going to hold
transactions and wallets is going to
hold wallets and then there's kind of
examples here of what they're going to
end up looking like
blockchain has some things there
and etc okay
um let's just see if we can't pass one
of these
tests or something
oh
look at that
that looks good
um
actually
whatever i'll just leave it
um
first one let's see
you can initialize running node in it
blockchain should replace everything in
blockchain.json with an array that has
one object the genesis block it should
have a hash property of zero
okay i think this one's not too
difficult
so
we've got two helper functions here
right blockchain right transactions um
should replace everything
right block chain
and that's this block equals to
so obviously the genesis block is the
first block in the blockchain which you
often have to hard code because you'll
find
it doesn't have a previous hash so you
can't
really generate a
hash for it
yeah so i have a hash of zero and a
previous hash of null
and then
the blockchain we're going to save
that but uh
blockchain should look like this
and i think
running that should do that okay
we could run it and see what it looks
like let me see what does my blockchain
look like
node
blockchain there it is
let's see there must be a test that goes
along with it
um running
all right we got the first one to pass
should replace everything so same thing
replace transactions.json with an empty
array um
currently it's empty but uh
if i go here right transaction so
right transactions
just like that
yeah these helper functions they just
kind of write to the file i guess and
get things from the files
the json
if we wanted to see what those helper
functions looked like
just in case maybe the name doesn't
describe them fully
where do we see that this is all on this
blockchain helpers file um there's a
bunch of
get and write blockchain
um it's pretty much just
well there's quite a few here i guess
getting balances and stuff um
but yeah you um should say here do not
change code in this file so you don't
need to change anything
um and it may mention some things about
some of them
elsewhere maybe in the instructions
okay
what do we got next
running nodegeneratewallet
with the username should add a user as a
key in waltz.json with a public key and
a private key properties the value
should be a public private keypair and
hex format
is the font so let's see what this one
looks like we have no wallets and
[Music]
generate wallet okay so we're going to
get a command
argument from the command line
um new wallet name
so
public and private i know there's
instructions on how to do this um
generate a key pair okay
so
let's go const key pair equals vc.gen
key pair
um ec is already here for us
and then
get some information from the keys
there's the user story on this one
to watch out for those type of
did i have a
typo yeah
um
should be able to create a wallet
well let's see what the examples look
like here we go wallet name public
private there we go that helps
okay so
mouse public
equals
um
get hex follow key from key pair
okay i think that's right
on
private equals
air that get
private
hex and then
get wallets so we don't want to
completely replace
um the wallets we want to add to it so
i think
house wallets equals get wallets
um
so
i guess we can probably just
skip some validation and do
wallets dot
new wallet name
so what validation would you do
i would make sure there's not a name
already in the wallet
right this is the only thing here
and
typically wallets aren't stored like
this this is just for this project
so you can see it and have access to all
the public and private keys
um okay so while it's in a wallet name
so we've got um
public key and private key
public
key
equals
public
well it's
dot new while named up private key
equals private
um
are those keywords
public and private so i'm getting
underlines
private is a reserve word
okay and then we should just do
right
wallets
and then if i say that
open my walls names yeah
node
so this is all in the instructions when
i have it somewhat memorized um but yeah
you can
create a wallet with this it says so
we're going to try that generate wallet
me
there's
not set
i was wondering if you needed to make
that
um
dynamic
yeah
okay so
equals
what's that new name
i'll just do this
this work
public key equals
pub
i'm not used to this keyboard
i think just remember new wallet name
is not the name of the key you want oh
is that my problem
yeah obviously
thank you um
that should work
i think
no more errors did or you must be
straying her buffer now what
invalid argument well when you're
writing wallets
you don't seem to be doing anything with
the wallet you just created
oh gosh
okay well it's equal get wallets
wallets your wallet's name well it's
worthwhile uh okay well it's thank you
you gotta look maybe i should have put
more
information there okay i think it worked
it worked
ha awesome
i think the fun thing about these
projects is you get to
you know try out what you're
making
as many times as you want
yeah you're cutting out a little but
yeah i got you
okay so we got one more thing done
hopefully
running the wallets creating wallet
works
and it has key pairs
when you generate a wallet it should add
a transaction at the end of the
transactions array
it should have a buyer address
property of null and um buyer just
property of null and seller address
that is the public key of the new wallet
okay so let's look at this
ad transaction i assume
go back to generate wallet get
transactions write transactions okay so
we'll just we wrote that
const
transactions
let's get transactions
and then
i guess const new
transaction
equals
something
then
transactions
dot push
transaction
transactions dot
right transactions
right um transactions right transactions
and then this transaction
it should add a
transaction at the end of the
transactions or the transaction buyer
address of null okay
seller
public key of the new wallet my price of
40.
so
public key
i'll just go like that
price
40.
i suppose the
i don't know
um but let's see what happens there okay
that didn't work either now now the old
one's broken
um new transaction equals that
transactions
you need to watch out for what you
actually named some of your variables
why don't you just tell me what the
answer is you see something don't you
seller address
pub
there is that what you were looking at
yeah
okay so now when i look at my wallets
um wallets we got two wallets
and
transactions we've got nothing in there
so i'm gonna just
like that one
i don't have a trackpad
where's my trackpad
um
well okay let's look third wallet test
okay we got a test wallet added that and
now we have a transaction
all right
um
running line my block should add an
object to the end of the blockchain.json
array
with the correct hash previous hash
nonce and transaction properties oh boy
so this
one sounds a little trickier
um
after you run should be an empty array
hmm
so i guess we're going to need a const
new block type thing
hash previous
hash
transactions
and something like that we'll see
equals
so
we've got helper functions
let's use those get blocked
blockchain
last
block
block chain
so you want to get the last block so we
can get the previous hash
so the blockchain is going to have this
and we're going to want to get
this hash
so we can put it on the next block and
it'll be the previous hash value of the
next block so last block equal
blockchain
blockchain
dot length
oh
this one
blockchain blockchain dot like that
sounds right
um
just comment this out once
also that log last block let's make sure
that's working
there it is okay so it's working
nice yeah
i wonder if you don't
need to worry about
mutating blockchain
you just pop it off the end
i mean in
this now you probably don't want to do
that right you would need to put it back
when you go back to write the block
chain
uh yes because you can't you can't
remove a block
okay previous equal last
block dot hash so we got one thing down
i think
um
not i think we're gonna have to look at
the rest of the things for that now okay
so hash and nots those are gonna be
tricky transactions let's
after you run
it should be an empty right okay we can
add that one quick
const
actually we should just be able to write
transactions
like that
think
so
assuming everything gets mined
correctly we can
make that an empty array um
i want to go up to these user sources i
think there's some information
generate a wallet okay so it looks like
we kind of got
a large portion of the top done
um
okay
the hash should be creating using
child56
okay concatenating the nonce the
previous the hash of the previous block
okay so yes we need to do some sort of
loop here
i guess let hash equals this
well and then i know there's something
in here about it having to start with
some zeros there we go the hash
and yeah what knots equals let's just
start with zero
so while
hash
starts with
zero zero
um
create new hash
hash equals
shot 256.
and then i think
how to work with keys shout out to
right there there it is
can i copy that
there we go okay content to hash
it says up here
um
the hash okay
concatenating the knots
nonce
plus
previous block
last
block dot hash
plus
a stringified version of whatever is in
transactions.json oh geez look at this
they copied
i could have just copied this whole
thing
just need to read
um transactions
there's some dots there
i don't have transactions
oh i think i do no i don't
it's
transactions
okay so
and then we want to probably do
nonce plus plus
we'll start
okay yeah so it's gonna keep going until
it starts with two zeros
nonsense be one two three four five
um
uh
okay apparently that should be the hash
of the last one
okay that looks right
um
yeah do you have everything for your new
block now
um
now it's hash
transactions is that just a jason
i think so yeah
yeah that looks right
let's see if it works so
the transactions are supposed to go
empty
and we're supposed to get a new block i
guess node mine block
um we did not get a new block because i
did not write it but i did delete the
transactions
um new block equals this uh
blockchain equal get blockchain
blockchain
dot
push
new
clock
and
right blockchain
blockchain
here we go
now we don't have any transactions but
um you know what i'm just going to
generate another wallet quick test two
now we have a transaction
and yet another wallet
okay let's see if that
worked note mine block all right no more
transactions and we have a block
three hundred dollars
um
[Music]
and then i guess i can come
run these tests and see what is passing
for me
uh running note mind blocks
hash previous hash nonce did i do
something wrong what have we got here
previous hash zero that looks correct
hash that looks correct knots looks
correct
oh boy
something is missing
transactions i'm wondering now
if you go back to your
your little algorithm for calculating
the hash
because i remember coming across this a
lot while doing
um
learning about the
cryptography of
blockchains
looking at the nonce that you're
calculating the hash with and then the
final nonce that you're ending up with
oh geez
let's just
we'll just do it first
[Music]
it's probably what's the right way to do
it
tell me the right way to do it
[Music]
okay let's see what happened
i'm just gonna get my cat still then
okay um
something isn't working
while not
we know the internet has an obsession
with cats so this is archie
did you pass that test
no
i wonder what the test is doing should
add an object
well i mean the one thing i can think is
you're not
if the hash the nonce needs to be zero
you're never actually testing that
what's that
say if the nonce is ever zero you're
never
calculating the hash based on that
because you're always
starting with one
kind of a probability of thing that
that's
probably not going to happen but
with the nonce
it'll go it just goes until it finds one
if zero but you know the checking zero
well that's fine because if zero works
it'll just go to one
and check one and then it'll go to two
or three whatever until it finds one
that works
and then you can use that one
uh i don't know i know what i'm gonna
try though
i'm hey
ans hash
wait did it pass running node my blocks
down object
and transaction property transactions
transactions
hmm
do you need to add a transaction anyway
i don't know i feel like that one should
have passed
well if you go to the console is it
saying anything
there you go now you're thinking
uh
i don't think we've even seen the
console yet
um yeah
okay
running on mine block let's see what it
says here the hash of the new block
should be able to be recreated
with these things expected zero zero six
maybe you're right what's the
to equal
zero
d so what one
so my hash has two zeros
i can't get back very easily i need my
touch
trackpad
um
so it's expecting only one zero
no it's just saying it's supposed to be
able to be recreated
dot hash
that should have been
correct
json.stringify
transactions
hmm
i'm gonna
check where you are
doing the dot two string
okay so what's transactions.json
online
oh there it is
yeah
oh stupid
transactions not transactions not json
did it say that and i should have copied
and pasted
not say that in the
instructions it did say that there's a
bug
no
well kind of a bug
it's a bug uh okay let's try it again
let's see if that works
console
running node mine block there it is we
got another one
thank you for that help
um
okay
so
do you mind writing that down you want
to take a note of that oh what are you
doing
yeah we'll take a note of that
um
okay
running node by item so we need to buy
and sell items
uh i'm already know about so we're going
to run this command by item with one of
our wallet private keys and the item we
want to buy and we need to add a
transaction for it
with the correct buy or just sell
address price unboxing so this is the
test text there must be more information
up here
so but i know we're going to need
cons let's call it new transaction
what's this and we're probably gonna
need
transactions equals get
transactions
you know it's always satisfying
when uh
you come across a problem like we just
had and then
you start to think that maybe you have
an issue with your tests
and then
find out that your test is working
okay
transaction when you buy an item yada
yada
so the buyer address should be the
matching public key for the private key
entered so it looks like we're going to
get a private key and we need to find
public key from that
because pub probably is probably the
keyword and russ isn't it
yeah
it is
um
so i have some poor
variable name choices maybe um so get
key pair from private
uh equal
different key
public keys because we got we should
have key from probably get key pair from
private so that'll give us a key pair
so that'll actually be key pair
and then we need i think
we need to
get
hex public key from key pair that should
work right here
so
um
i'm just going to
console
that shouldn't do anything
save that um
so i should be able to run
node
i
item and enter
a
private key
so if i grab this private key
and run it
oh come on
why can't i paste
copy paste
i should get a log
with the public key
that is the public key that matches that
works okay
so we have a public key
um
okay we need to run that
so okay
fire
press
public key
seller
address null
price should be the purchase price of
the item bought
item bot equals that so
get item price
what does that do
get out of price item items so it looks
like
it returns the price
i think you can just do
get
right here
right in the object
item price
item bot
um
signature should use the buyer's key
pair to sign oh geez
signature
equals
buyer's key pair
keep hair dot sign
here we go
what kind of content do we need
by concatenation buyer address price in
item bot
and these helper functions are really
just making a lot better aren't they
yeah uh
i lost it price item bot okay
price plus item bot
okay so we should have a signature
and we need to add it probably down here
we don't want that why would i do that i
think
thank god for linting
it'd be terrible
okay so
supposed to add an object to the
transactions transactions dot push
new transaction
right transactions transactions
save it and we will i'm going to open up
this
transactions and see if i can do
this again node by item
and
we'll try an icon
but i wanted to see
this
notebook
oh
something's out of order
buyer address equals public key buyer
address um
so i should be able to just do public
key there
bank
price is not defined
get item price
um
[Music]
price
okay yeah
it
item price item bought
yeah that wasn't very smart there was it
let's try it again
yeah i think i spent 10 or 15 minutes
yesterday on a bug that was caused by
a trailing comma in json
yeah so at least your error messages are
telling you you know exactly what's
wrong mine was telling me unexpected
token
now
well
didn't it give you like a red line
around it and it's just really small and
you can find it didn't get a red line
around it
no i think i was editing in nano so
oh yeah
no anything
okay
so i think this one should be working
we bought an item and it was there
so
mind block no buy item
buyer seller
signatures well let's see what happened
with this transaction buyer seller price
signature
buyer seller price item we're missing an
item
i wonder what the console would have
told you
we'll check it out here in a second
yeah
i'm always interested if it's
assertions are specific enough
seven
i mean i don't know this one might be a
little
i really
need my trackpad for this oh i have to
scroll down here i guess that's not bad
i just go scroll down a little further
um expected 2 to equal 3. that's not all
that helpful
are you asserting the length of the
object's properties yeah i guess
probably huh
yeah
um
and then somewhere in there i suppose i
checked the rest of it
yeah that's not or maybe i should check
something
anyway
um
i think it'll work now
and since i'm just
all right i'm still failing
let me see if i buy an item again what
now what
icons we got item
higher chests
to read
read my own stuff
still nothing
itembot signature
[Music]
let's run it one more time
what
i notice your transactions aren't
um
clearing
oh you're not running mind block that's
why
yeah
seller address i don't see any typos
signature
hmm
let's see if that console's changed
because
it's adding an item
it's going to say the same thing isn't
it
that's not helpful um
buyer address
buy item
enterprise so the price is correct
signature i wonder if that's off public
key
fire address that's the same thing that
shouldn't matter
signature let's see what that signature
is supposed to be
you buy an item
signature
sign concatenation of the buyer address
price
and item bot
in that order in hex format
we've got to keep here
keep here that sign
i mean the signature's here so
um
cellular address it's supposed to be
null right
seller address should be no price should
be the purchase price
10. i wonder if that's supposed to be a
string no
let me see this example
transactions
yeah it all looks correct
[Music]
hmm
transactions we're pushing it
get address balance
is there a caveat in there that i'm
supposed to make sure they have a
enough funds
well it sounds like it's saying you're
still not pushing the correct number of
objects
that is what it's saying
but
you know what i think it might be
yeah
something to do with the balance
the test is checking if it's got enough
balance or something
so i'm gonna go
i'm gonna start over
i'm gonna reinitialize my blockchain
and
because the account i'm using is this
one that i created that doesn't have any
funds
and add the funds until those other
that there were uh it's like a
i guess a
reward transaction for
creating a wallet
node generate wallet
just put me in there see now i'm going
to have
transaction with the funds i created
those other wallets before those
transactions were in there so
i don't know why that would that why
would that have anything to do with it i
don't know
i'm gonna run these tests again see if
it still came back
yeah there it is i'm gonna look at my
solution
see if there's anything
well i can't think of anything
transactions price buyer keeper key from
private
signature
it looks the same
for the most part very similar
copy it over
still nothing oh
i didn't save the file
i wonder if i wasn't saving the file
i need to turn on autosave
there it passed
so now we don't even know if we're i'm
going to undo this and see
if it's working undo save
and then run it
no no it's not passing i wonder what i'm
missing on this one
fire is just cilantro's
keep hair
all right um we have to do the cell item
thing still so
we'll give it another try over there i'm
just gonna use my solution for now
because it's passing
um
i feel like it didn't have anything to
do with the balance but maybe i'll dig
into the test later and see if
i
wonder when you sign it the
concatenation it matters the order
doesn't it
did you have the order correct
i did
i double checked it
public key price item bought
buy your address
public key
yeah
okay
wow
do you have to do the check for the the
balance in order to pass that one
it doesn't
say anything about it
should not add a transaction if the
address it does not have a
maybe
it's right there i didn't look at the
second one
get this one
run the test
okay these both fail yeah maybe i'll
just try transaction equal that
transaction number so
let's try it once
yeah
get address balance um
cons balance
equals get address balance
public key
if
um balance than or
equal to
price
we'll
add the transact uh push transaction and
write the transactions
let's try that once and see
maybe that was it
there it is
wow
you want me to take a note of that
um
i mean there might be a reason that's
happening perhaps
yeah sure take a note um
yeah i don't like that but
maybe i'll put that user story first
that's probably what i would do
um okay running the cell item so what
else did we get we've got a cell item
i should have at least three wallets in
my wallet so jason so that's what i was
gonna do here me you
i three wallets i should be able to pass
that one
um
three loss okay and then at the end here
we got a
oh they are valid nice at the end we
gotta add a bunch of blocks and
transactions okay sell item
let's try this all item one let's keep
keep moving
keep me on keep me on task sean
yeah well you're almost there
i'm almost there
um
so we need to sell item
address private key and item so the the
command will have the private key
and an item
and we gotta add another transaction
with the buyer address so let me go to
my buy item once
i just do a little
this is going to be a bad idea but i'm
going to copy this over here
a new transaction
transactions
i'm just i'm just all over the map with
my code too just
hacking away
okay let's move some of these up to the
top um well i don't think we need a
price on this one but
okay so the buyer address is going to be
null this time
seller address should be
public
key i believe
quick buyer just seller just price and
item sold price
item sold and then i believe we actually
don't add a signature to this one
because we're selling an item back to
the game
or maybe we do i don't know
oh it does say signature
yes so we do need
i don't know what i was talking about
um
there's something you don't need a
signature for though i thought
i don't remember
oh it was the reward transactions
um okay so i'm gonna
scroll up to the sell item
thing here so we're supposed to add that
buyer address should be null seller just
be the
matching public key for the private key
hundreds so we've got a
seller private key that comes in
and we have to keep here
there and then their public key
okay so we got the public key
um
price should be five less than the
purchase price of the item
so we have item sold
price
equals get item price i should just be
able to go minus five
there
um
signature should use seller key pair to
catenate seller
address
price and item sold
um so public key should still work price
items sold
there we go um
you shouldn't need uh
shouldn't need anything here
i'm wondering if there's supposed to be
something
that makes sure they have the item
before they can sell it but i don't see
anything written
well you might need to check your actual
user stories
no maybe
i only kind of skimmed over them
seller address
yeah i don't see i'm selling i'm not
okay
so we do
if
um
what is it
get address items
um i should be able to
address
cons
items equals get address items
on the key
i think
so
i'm gonna cancel log
items
here
and nothing should be happening because
i'm not writing any files so
what i want to do
is
get an item to somebody somehow
transactions we don't have any items yet
so node buy item
and i want to see if
when you buy an item
you should be able to buy an item by
running by private key item
okay
private key
let's do a different item this time
a spray
i think it worked
actions
there it is okay so now we have a spray
we can sell let's just add
another one we have two
um
and it says that the transaction pool is
included
uh the items are so this should be
included so if i go node
sell item
um
that private key
get in there
get item price item bot minus five yeah
maybe i can't do that
um oh it's because i didn't put in an
item
no
oh is it can i not do that either
what is it you see something you need to
tell me
it's not item bought
item sold
all right
all right
although i'm not inputting an item here
okay so there we go we've got my items
here they are
that worked everything worked
so i need to say if
uh not items
items
item sold
greater than zero
or actually you know what let's just do
if items i am sold greater than one so
if you have at least one
you can then
do something
transactions dot
push
come on
new
transaction
transaction start right
now you keep wanting to do that
oh it's just
it feels natural okay
yeah
there
i think that'll work let's see what
happens if i sell one of these sprays
console like my items but that was
before it actually changed
transactions
yeah there it is
and i can i think there's the helper
function here
i thought items
gift items
oh yeah there's a little
you can run that to gift items let's run
that ones
gift items
i think it should work
now
it sends an item to every wallet
around item
yep free item to every wallet
okay
that's a funny drop
um
i wanted to check the balance
or get address info there we go
node get
uh address
info and i think if i just do the name
there we go
so we can we have some info there
it has a balance of 20
and a few items
there we go
that's kind of nice um
and let's see if the selling test passed
across our fingers here
no
no big fail
so i don't
what dude let me
know it's cell item actually i'm just
gonna
node
mine block
should clear out the transactions and
then
sell item okay so now i just have
none
i thought it was working before i must
not have that item
what address is that
um
okay
node
you're also saying if it's greater than
one hey
note items that item sold if it's
greater than or equal to one
there we go thank you
there it is
um
and yet it did not pass but i guess that
was probably the problem so let's try it
again
there it is it passed
all right
there's off by one errors
um
and now we just need to add a bunch of
transactions and
stuff like
that so
node
node mine block
just pop these open i'm going to pop
these open here so we can see what's
going on
blockchain
if you got a blockchain here what looks
like about three blocks
no
i hit them
and we need wallets
so i think if i grab a key
hotkeys don't work
excuse me
free
action work
there it is so this person is buying a
spray two sprays
that one didn't work because we don't
have enough money
sure we'll just mine it
this person
node
by item
paste
uh i'll do icon
just make three transactions
to buy some icons we'll just mine
another block
node
gift items
node gift items
block
yeah you can see it it keeps adding
to this array blockchain and
transactions so it's kind of neat um
and
i wonder how many more we need let's see
if i have any passing i don't think
that's enough though
i just add a bunch of addresses
two addresses minor block
we're gonna we're gonna do this
mode cell item
that's
uh
icon
both
line block
generate wallet this is what you want
this is what you want
um sean right now we have our own
wallets
40 coins each
um
node mine block
let's see how far we got
ten blocks
no
gift items
mine black
does not tell you in the console how
close you are
no
okay that's gotta be enough
there we go
nice
oh one project down
okay let's move on to the next project
um
yeah we finished this one
and the next one is uh build a
fundraising smart contract
so it's going to be
kind of similar and that's got a bunch
of json files and stuff
where you put your blockchain in there
um
okay let's see what it says here it says
i need to create and deploy a smart
contract that raises funds for my
startup the goal is to raise 150 tokens
before the seventh block is mined
you have some boilerplate code and
files um i should not need to change any
of the boilerplate code the fundraising
contract folder is the only place i need
to write code so i have this folder
which is going to be my contract
and the rest of this stuff is
not stuff i need to change anyway
okay the initial state it's the an
object my contract will store js files
in that folder
[Music]
um
will be run by the contract
on transaction will run when a
transaction is sent to the address of my
contract and the on new block will run
when a new block is mined
and then it says that
the files or the functions on the
contract can only run if the status of
the
contract is open
so
yeah this is my contract state object
and i presume there's going to be some
sort of status
open or maybe that
automatically gets added
okay
the only two helper functions your
contract files can use are add
transaction and update contract state
they're already added in your contract
files
okay so we've got an on new block file
that will run when
new block is added and this on
transaction will run when
a transaction is set to the contract
address and then these other files is
just
showing all the things you can use in
any other file you're gonna need to add
here i know we're going to need to add a
couple i think
uh it says there's a number of variables
that we passed your contract files
uh
ones available are already defined there
and those two files uh
yeah so it says there
then we can use those variables um
and here's the command to deploy your
contract
it says it will create a contract
address and put the contract itself in
the smart contracts
json
thing
and then it will get added to the
blockchain the next time i mine a block
after it's deployed you can run the
contract files with this
command
um
yeah
and there's some notes here says mining
a block creates a reward transaction
with a random address from wall such as
okay
these are stories bonus hints
there's a lot of hints
so there's
gonna be a lot of like
okay
hence do this first i'm gonna do this
first because it says do this first
there's a there's an example contract
for you to
okay do this first it will help you
understand how contrast there's an
example contract for you to play with to
see what it can do keep your eye on your
json files and run these commands
um so we've got like transactions
smart contracts maybe blockchain
we want to
i'm in the wrong folder from before so i
better make sure i switch
build a
run this initialize blockchain okay we
got a block
node
deploy contract example
contract because that's the name of the
folder here
and then a private key from the wallets
private key let's go with this one
um
okay so we should have a message i guess
your contract has been deployed at the
address
it will be added to the blockchain on
the next block as well cool
nice
so
there it is and it has my like functions
from the example contract folder
and the state of the contract i guess so
node
block i'll do that
now it moved over there it's blocked in
a transaction a private key from all its
transaction okay so
so do you want to explain what's in that
functions object
it's the code from these
files these javascript files
so you're just
taking the code as a string and sticking
it all on one line
yeah
yeah
it works
it's uh
i mean it's
it's pretty similar to how i mean not
maybe not that part of it is but
it's kind of similar to real smart
contracts and that
the code goes on to the blockchain
and that's i guess more the purpose of
of kind of some of this is to get the
concepts across
i don't know
i think it's nice
i think it
definitely
helps for debugging
all right um
let's
try and do
a little more here node
add
private key from wallets
um so the contract is now like a
different address
and this person this wallet created it
so you could still use that wallet
to send things to the contract now
um probably from almost example contract
address and i'm pretty sure nobody has
any coins
or maybe they do i don't know
so i have to use zero for the amount
then some
thing hopefully to the
there you go
so i sent
xero
to the contract address
and it says someone set a transaction
it is running it's on transaction file
here's what the transaction looks like
and if you look at the example contract
this one
it has all that information you get
a transaction that came in and just a
couple logs
okay so it ran that file
and then you can also run
contract example contract to just get
favorite number
okay node run contract
temple contract address should be that
it
before it
i spell that right
no you're missing the you in favorite
huh
okay
look at this we got running this file
favorite number is 10
and then we can set it
is your your favorite number actually 10
no i don't have a favorite number
example contract
no it's actually 11 that's why we're
going to change it to 11.
favorite
number
yeah
i'm kind of missing
uh like you usually you need a private
key you know to
update state
right to the blockchain i guess we don't
in this one
which is fine
but i ran that and
now it should be
there it is and
if you were to look through
some of these
blockchain files you'd see all that kind
of happening
like i guess
there's the transaction okay this the
smart contract transactions basically
transactions go in their own
file
um
let's see what happens when i mine a
block
yeah and then everything from both these
files gets
moved over to the blockchain yeah let's
try to get a
random reward on a new block his mind
and he
yeah so smart contracts kind of have
their own area here
um but i guess typically on real
blockchains they're just regular
transactions but yeah who are you
nothing
okay
let's okay
let's try and
get this
going
fundraising contract so
the initial state should have a status
set to open
and
a
description
to
smart contract
your contract should have a get
description file
uh so we're gonna
we these are the new files we need to
make new file get description
dot js
and update description so it doesn't
make those two updates
and
console.log
i don't know if i can copy that maybe
that's a good thing
i'm just mumbling to myself here
what's going on over there sean
i'm just watching you seeing how
the master does it
creating smart contracts
yep
um
keep your eyes open for those tables i'm
good at that
yeah i think that's why mostly here
um
so get description
console.log
here's the description
of the fun
contract and then
description here
probably
contract state dot
description
so the contract state will be
the object here
yeah
but we need to actually deploy the
contract for any of this to work
i don't think i need
any of that i think we just need this
one
okay
updates the description
um
updates the description so
update contract state
um
i wonder if i should look in here i
think
i wonder if it's explained in here
what that function needs
remember you can just go to the you can
hover over the function
definition and then
control click all
command click
not convinced you can in these ones but
maybe what do you do command clicked
there
who do i press
um
i'm not sure what it is on mac if it but
don't mind it's control and then i click
on it and it takes me to the definition
although no you have dynamic imports so
it might not do that
so
update contracts did and why
update contract state address state
there we go
okay contract address contract address
and then comma
we need
a new
thing
something from there
args
go with zero for now
i don't think i need i think you could
just console log it couldn't you
yeah we'll throw that in there anyway
doesn't need
any of that
or
that
a contract address no
it needs the whole state object
so it would be
contract state contract
contract state dot
description
equals
um
args zero maybe i'm gonna go with that
but i don't know we'll see what it says
let's make sure we save the file
um
and then
let's attempt to
deploy it i think maybe
sure
so i'm going to follow the
commands from deploying the example
contract
here we're going to reinitialize
deploy
prising contract
and then a private key
based
there we have it
so let's just
align that to the block chain
and then
we should be able to run these functions
node
run contract
it's description.js
the description that worked
and then
date description
new description
network
yeah look at that arc zero
working
nice
well let's see if the test passed i
guess huh
look at all these we got past already
wow
how many left to do
not too many
nine ten
oh this one's past two
this one's past two
your fundraising contract should be
deployed in mine's election
all right okay
so running the commands to play your
contract
and sending it the 150 tokens
created transactions
so
our contract needs to
raise 150 tokens
before the seventh block is mined
and if it
does
we need to create a transaction that
sends all the funds donated
from the contract to the address of the
creator
and then also set the status
to closed
and if we
do not raise the 150 before seven blocks
we
need to send
the transactions back to the
people that sent them to us
okay
so you have to keep that all in state
now use sent what
so
initial state
i guess um
maybe
donated
transactions
and then maybe an array
and a
um
raised maybe like a number
status description
i think that might be enough
so you definitely need to keep track of
all the transactions
that come in
so we can send them back
and
i think that'll work
i don't know if we need to keep track of
the raised or not
you could just look through the
transactions i suppose
so that sounds like an optimization
thing that
you may or may not want to do
yeah
okay so this on new transaction comes
when our contract gets a
donation
so we're going to need to if we get a
transaction what do we need to do
put it in
the state
also
add two raised or something add the
funds to raise i'll just keep track of
it for the heck of it i don't know
i need it um
and then we need to check if we have the
150
send
all funds to
contract creator
something like that maybe
um
yeah i'd go with that
okay so
contract state
so a transaction comes in let me
console.log
transaction fill that in there what does
a transaction look like when it comes in
yeah
probably an amount
and the address would be the contract
address and the from address would be
um whoever sends it
so
this is tricky
update contract state
contract
address new state
um
the state has a
transactions object so you know what i'm
just gonna go
we have this contract state here so i'm
just gonna contract
state
transactions
not
push
this work
no
transaction
what's that transaction that came in
and then
we could also do contract
say dot
is
plus equal
transaction dot amount maybe
i'm not sure you can plus equals on a
property
you can't
thanks
um
contract state.raise um equals
wait
yeah you can
can't you
contract it dot raised
plus equals
so you can try yeah
i don't see why not
maybe i don't know
um where am i at here
okay so
we've got a few things happening update
contract state
add to raised
and then should i attempt to do this
right now or should i
there are helper functions for
running contract
earning contract
playing contract wallet um
i thought there's one for
getting just the whole state
i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna do this once
throw another one in there why not
it stayed console.log
contacts
we're gonna do that
let's just see what happens i should be
able to deploy this
and we'll see a transaction we'll do
that
update the state and then we'll be able
to check it with that other file
okay so
um
go back
reinitialize and then redeploy
and
find the block
and what we want to do is send a
transaction to it so
if i look at transactions there's one
there
i suppose i could send zero to it
let's mine another block
so now
somebody has 50. this person
public key that's their public key
though
wallets
zero four one two
so here's their private key
to be able to go
add a transaction
from this person this is probably all in
the instructions it's just i kind of
have it memorized
um
helpers maybe down here add transaction
i guess okay we already went through
that
um so we take the private key
and then
the
to address which would be the contract
address
very large address
i made sure to make them as big as i
could
yeah that always seemed like it when i
looked at these
no i did the opposite actually but
okay so we have problems um
is my transaction though the transaction
came in
yeah
undefined 15 new state well that is the
problem
contract address
contract state
all right let's try it again
initialize
deploy
unlock let's do that twice we have a
transaction
node add transaction
um
private key private key very key
here we got this person0416
um contract address
and
50.
i think it worked
okay
so what files have changed
this one right here
transaction showed up from
that person to the contract address this
is we just sent this to the contract
and it did some things there with
signatures
um
and then the contract ran this
file here
yeah
so we got this log of the transaction
that came in
and then if we say get
state now
it should all be
updated node
run contract
east
getstate.js
it is smart
status open transactions
nice
okay awesome
so
now we need to do like if
if contract
contract state dot raise greater than or
equal to 150
um
send all phones to creator just like i
put right there
um so we need to
add
transaction
creator address
so i suppose that would be their
public key
of the creator
and private key
well
wouldn't you first
send if wouldn't you first put all the
transactions into the blockchain
that the contract has stayed for and
then
send a transaction from the
contract to the owner
say that again
so
your contract state has a bunch of
transactions in it you need to mine
those
so that the contract address has those
funds
and then you need to
from the contract address send
a transaction
to the owner
well
i'm just storing the transaction
information in the contract state the
actual transactions are also going into
the transaction they're already going
through right cool right so they're
already going on to the blockchain
okay
i just need the information so that if
my contract
does not
succeed
i can
send all this stuff back and i probably
probably only need like
the from address
and the amount from each transaction
that would be enough to send it back
so i'm gonna
i'm gonna do that i think
on transaction
you know what i'm not gonna do that
all right um
so
what was i looking at here this private
key i presume
is that the private key
of the contract itself maybe
that's kind of hacky but
you can
[Music]
yeah you need to you need to sign it
from the contract
no
yeah
and so
i wanted to find this function and see
what it looks like
add transaction
somewhere
you know what there's this thing you can
find
right in here somewhere
private key to address amount
add transaction
private key
to address creator address
amount
contract state dot raise
that sounds right
so you're definitely sending everything
through
even if it's over the goal
yeah
yeah isn't that how real fundraisers
work you can raise you know you set a
goal of something
ten thousand but you can also raise much
more
like a lot of future
pretty sure that's awful have you ever
watched shark tank
no maybe not
i have and that's what they say on shark
tank
we raised twenty thousand on a goal of
ten thousand that's what i
say um well i mean if you have let's say
you raise 140 from previous transactions
and then somebody wants to donate
another 100 to get to 240.
where would that other money go who
would get it well i don't know i'm used
to things like kickstarter where you
have a goal of
10 000 but then some of these
you know some kickstarters they have a
goal of
10 000 and they get a million
i'm pretty sure that they don't get to
use the million
all right
it doesn't matter
that's how this one works
okay yeah
um
so
i think this file might be done and i
don't even know i'm just gonna click
this run test
let's see what happens maybe that one
will pass
running and send it there it is so if
the 150 tokens get sent
yeah
it worked
nice
oh but i also need to
so
add a transaction i guess i need to
update
contract
state dot status equals
close maybe i think that's what i'm
supposed to do
and update contract state just
copy
um
would just move that line to the bottom
of the file
all right
yeah
that's good girl
yep
is it supposed to be a capital c
here
no they're closed
um
[Music]
what did these users say no it does not
look like it
okay i guess we'll run the test then i'm
gonna have to go through that process of
deploying
there it is
now we need
yeah
now we need to
do this other one on new block
this is whatever block it's mined we
need to
if block
length
greater than 7 or something
send all
transactions back to
donors i guess
yeah something like that
okay
in my mind you should count
the block number from when the contract
is deployed and then seven after that
you definitely should that sounds better
obviously it could
be tough to
do things with time or something which
is what you really would probably want
to do
yeah
yeah that would have been that would
have been better
why don't you tell me that sooner
all right
this is this is how it is though for now
and
yeah that's a bonus to hear if i was
going to go through this they can
at the end switch up their their
contract so that it
finds out the block that it was deployed
and then
the logic is seven after
it's deployed block
now
i like that
um
so we're gonna have
contract
state.transactions
uh
for each maybe
what the heck is that
maybe some sort of loop to go over all
these
transactions
um
a transaction
and it was the
we got the private key
so this is
from
the contract
to
tx dot
from address
i think
and
to mix that amount
that looks right
i think so
so yeah if
blockchain length which comes in
running the commands to deploy your
contract and mine seven blocks so
i think there's a note in here
about
something when this is actually run
it says in
immediately after the block is mined
yeah is that what it says
yeah
so it should be
greater than or equal to seven i think
um
okay
is that it
i can't be it
we need to also if block change
do
update you know screw this
copy this
contract state let's just do
if watching length not greater than
seven
and
contracts not already closed
uh
not equal to
closed it's kind of sketchy
condition there
should work
yeah
not good enough for me
um
so if it's not closed
update to contracts dude
contract state.status
equals closed
and i'm around the test
i might be missing something but it
looks pretty good
there it is
wow
all right apparently my functions are
working
yeah
now we need to kind of start over and
deploy it and actually send it enough
transactions i think like it says the
current state the
status closed and a description oh it
says description
your contract should have had at least
150 tokens sent to it
and it should have added a transaction
sending all the
tokens back to the creator or to the
greater whatever
so
we have to kind of do that i'm just
going to start over
initialize
deploy
i'm just going to mine how many do i
need 150
so like six blocks so i can
have tokens descend
just flooding the market here
block chained up jason all those wait
what
where are my transactions oh they're
there they're here i just didn't scroll
down
so now i should be able to go we
deployed it
um
node add transaction from
wallets
private key
to
um
oh geez
copy
paste
it's like the slowest copying and
pasting you'll ever see
paste okay so from somebody
to the contract let's see it
a person doesn't have any money figures
from
this person
no
there
okay that should work
transaction to the contract
so i think if i just
do it again
do you have three
no no you're out of money
all right well that should be enough for
this
oh that's only two
actually 100 it's supposed to be 150.
that
first one was one of these
well now you've mined too many blocks
haven't you
no it says your blockchain should have
at least six blocks oh maybe i have
because at some point it's gonna
oh no
at some point it's gonna send the money
back
oh yeah crap
you're right
um
just delete the last json
yeah that that could potentially work a
little hack but
node add
transaction
ah i know that transaction we're gonna
go like this
did it work did i get did it happen
and cine logs
um
ours 150 i think
yeah i wonder if i need to mine the
block
i don't think so
maybe i maybe i mined too many blocks
already and you were right
let me
know to run
might be in here
contract wallets
i think i use the public
address i'll paste it in there let's say
get state.js
closed
now
i blew it
all right we're gonna start over yet
again
yay
specialize
maybe you don't mind six blocks just
minding three
oh i'm pranking
we have
zero blocks now we have one block
two blocks three blocks
we do four so that we have
enough coins
on the blockchain it should be
there's our first block you could also
just manually edit one of the
um
wallets to have 100
or 200. no you can't
there's a test that checks that your
blockchain's valid
i could change the function that
yes
um
it's node add transaction from
private key
i realized yeah my hotkeys are working
to
the contract
and
50.
okay you're out of money
um
we'll try you
that should be it
transacted
there it is the
150 wow
now if i run the test is that it
no you don't have six blocks
oh
your contract should have had at least
100 seconds and should have added a
transaction sending all the contracts i
wonder
oh boy none of that looks good
maybe i just need to mine it
yeah
before you reach this xbox be sure to
edit the description
that's true huh thanks
okay so what have i got here i don't
even know
i'm not gonna worry about it
let's let's do this node
run
contract
contract
address
i think he's the public key
um
update description
dot js
smart contract
to raise funds for my startup
oh fine one more block
press their fingers
you cannot update the state of a
contract that is not open what
oh
whoever created this is just
evil
i guess i wanted you to go through all
of this i gotta do it again
unbelievable
okay
i guess it's some good practice so we
deployed our contract i'm gonna
node my block
imagine how much easier this would have
been
if your addresses were a reasonable
length
[Music]
or if my hotkeys were even working
my hotkeys are
i can't paste into the terminal i don't
know why
with ctrl v or whatever
i don't know
so we have my contract so the first
thing we're going to do run contract
contract
address
update
description
dot js
smart
contract raise
funds for
i
start up
i'm going to just run the tests and
see if
make sure it's passing before something
crazy happens in the current state
oh well
yeah that's that's pretty rough there
now let me tell you the problem because
someone's going to come along they're
going to forget the period at the end of
that description
and
they're going to mine all of their
blocks
and they're going to fail that last test
all part of it
yeah
okay so if you check the console though
you can probably see whether it's
failing because of the description or
because the status property is closed
yeah you might be able to
so you get that
contract address
paste
50
money i
can't address info so i mean i could be
doing that
but i'm just
copying
probably the same
same time to do both
so you have all the money or i forgot to
mine a block or something
oh i definitely mind blocks
who has the money
what's going on here
we've got a blockchain
50 50 50. somebody's got money
it's
it's probably the
yeah
that worked
i know
name of address
count your property is not divine
saying get water to dress is returning
undefined
all right you want to make a note of
that one too
yeah
oh no never mind i just had a typo
it's a capital m
okay
okay so here is the public address
and the balance
for me
did i not do it right
private key
i'll copy it
i swear i did this already
transactions
i don't see any
node get address info
i don't see any 150 transactions yet so
or whatever coins
so let's do this one
paste
there
should be it a little anticlimactic but
no to get
it's gonna try and run the account i'm
gonna do it node run
run contract
copy
paste
get state touches
the transactions are all still there
close smart contract
good thing i didn't have a period
missing or something let's find let's
find out maybe there's typo
come on fingers crossed
oh it's still failing
this should all be that those two should
be working a smart contract to raise
funds for my startup
get to the console
sure
yeah this is not going to be helpful
like
expected thank you did you mind the
block
maybe not
yeah
maybe i need to do that let's try it
this one say
actual open expected closed
all right let's try it maybe i just
needed to mine it
come on
it was
whew
wow
well we got another one
so
nice work
all right um
the next project is this peer-to-peer
network
so let's just try and check it out
um
that's
so
when i click on it it starts me down
here
yeah it's because it's a
single page app
so the scroll location is staying the
same
okay so
yeah it's pretty minor but
i guess what we're gonna try and do here
is build a peer-to-peer network
sort of
what gave that away
that was the title right
it's distributed
so
we're gonna be working in this folder
um we have some boilerplates we don't
need to change any of that an old one
folder right here represents
a node on the network the files in it
will be cloned and used to run all the
other nodes in the network you only need
to change the index.js file
um
so we're going to use websockets and
websocket servers to create a website
server in here and it's going to listen
for incoming connections and it's going
to
connect to all the other nodes on the
network uh
so
once we think we have this file finished
what we're going to do is run this clone
node
thing to copy it
and then
run a bunch of different nodes i
guess and so we have to have at least
three nodes
and we need to create a websocket server
and so basically all the servers are
gonna connect to each other
we have these like known peers which are
kind of like entry points to the network
and then once one of the sockets
connects to one of those entry points
it will handshake with the
server and the server will send it the
list of all of its connected addresses
so and then from there it will connect
to every other node on the network
so we're basically
simulating a
creating
a flood sub
network
um
protocol
sure
um
yeah uh
i don't know to be honest that's
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with it sure
um
so
we're gonna have to have some
server
listening
um
when it starts it should attempt to open
soccer
so it should attempt to
connect to
known
peers
uh when i saw your connection when a
connection to server is established
okay so we're going to try and connect
to these and if we
find a connection
we need to send it a string object
that says this type
and shake
data
ray
so it looks like we have
the address of the server here
um
data should be an array of addresses
that your server is connected to
including the server's owners so data
connected addresses that's what we need
um
my
yes
connected
addresses
something like that
when a server receives the above message
it should attempt to open socket
connections so
when i connect to a server i send it
this
and when my server receives this
so
something like
server
dot on
and shake
connect
yeah
do all
data
um
[Music]
you should keep track of all the
addresses the server is connected to you
can use that
when a socket disconnects
you should remove it
so i guess
that would be possibly like socket dot
on
clothes i think
move from
rey
something like
you should keep track of the servers you
are attempting to make make connections
do not try to make more than one
connection to the same server
okay
and then after you connect remove it
there's some issue i remember adding
that there's some issue that was
causing an infinite loop of
servers connecting to each other
yeah
uh server should never attempt to create
a connection to its own address you
should clone your node one folder at
least two times all of your nodes should
have the exact same code with the
exception of the env file um you should
have at least real three nodes running
use those ports
all of your
nodes should have an open socket
connection to all other nodes um
there's a bonus there hints adding
console logs
can really help
websocket servers
okay here this looks
promising
copy i can't even copy from there can i
yes i can
server
port so
make this server
and the part is going to be
my
port
and then server.on connection
so
to create a server listening on the
given port i wonder
so that's listening already server.on
connection
log
connection three
seed
that
socket that on message runs when i suck
it sends a message to your server
nest it within the connection function
you want to make a note of this i'm
missing closing parentheses right here
so we have a string that comes in that's
console.log
message received
and i'll just go plus data string i
think that'll be
this
for sure
so
and how to work with sockets so here's
like your server
and then
you kind of want a second thing which is
opening
a socket connection to the server
from the server
yeah so you want to act as a server a
websocket server and as a websocket
client
pretty much
um
uh
let's run the test
i got one
nice
um
okay when a node opens the socket
connection
so the first thing we want to do
is try to connect i know i need a
connect function so i need like this
function
connect address that's what i'm going to
do
and
the first thing we want to do is up here
anyway um
we need to attempt to open
a connection to all those addresses so
something like
known appears that
each
here
connect
here
council log
something to connect to
here
address
save it and we'll just see if anything
happens
so i have to go actually into this
node one folder and then i can run
that okay
and something is running you're
attempting to connect
and it is still running it is not
stopping running
but
successfully made a for each call
loop
um
so
if we want some catches here if address
not equal to my
address so we don't want to try and
connect to
our own address and
and we're not
something to connect to it
and
not attempting
clues address i think that should work
so we can actually test that
i'll leave that console log in there and
this first node has a
port of
4001 i think yeah
that's
my own address so we'll not attempt to
connect that
to only attempt to connect to that one
all right
so
attempt
attempting to connect
addresses dot push
we are now attempting to connect to an
address
yeah when
i went through this i remember i wanted
to use
sets
just because i think it
works quite well when you have
elements that you don't want to repeat
and
that you want to easily remove
so that's just a
did it work
did it work or not
yeah no it works it's just you need to
remember when you're
passing it through the api to
i think sets have a two array method or
else you just have to say array from and
then pass the set in
yeah
yeah
okay
so when a socket connection to a server
is established send a message to the so
i think
we want to move this handshake message
and
trying to connect and then
once we do connect we want to
send this
um
you go to these helper
syntax
server sockets
so think we do yeah that looks right
so all in here we're going to try to
connect to this address
on open on close on air
runs when any connection is served has
been established so that sounds
promising
so i should in here want to send this
message
suck it dots and
that some data
wanted to be
i just go
i can't go like that
is it jason that stringify or is it
something to string i think string of
fireworks here yeah it's jason
yeah that's what i do whenever i'm
working with websockets
um
i think i'm missing
another one of these
maybe i'll just
give myself a little
more
formatting there and i don't know why
i'm getting four spaces that is
no good
but i can handle it for now
okay so let's uh let's throw
that's a log
connection
open so you know what else we need to do
a
attempting to connect to addresses
splice or something
and then find
press
one that won't work with it
no i think you need to do the
attempting to connect addresses dot find
index
yeah it's the index something
um
so can i
do
something
to
connect
addresses dot index
of
i think that'll work
let's see how many off for one errors
there are
so and then
we want to
go to connected addresses dot push i
think
address so we have now connected
action open
and then suck it dot
on
clothes
it
on
here
i'm probably just i'll just throw some
console out i'll pull that log
they're connecting
to
run through that there
tempting
i'm gonna remove it from this
um
and then on close
we should just
addresses
from there
it's going well i think although it may
all crash and burn on me but we'll see
i'm trying to think all of the things
that fire the
error event
that's emitting area event
for sockets because
what happens if you splice and index of
returns negative one
so right now you're treating it as if on
error only happens when there hasn't
when
on open hasn't happened
now
um
here
i don't know what splice does if
attempting to
connect dot index of returns negative
one
because it might
start from the
the back of the array and then just
remove some random last element
drawn here
um
i'm gonna
bring this tab over
i think you're on to something
so if i splice a negative one
one
this turns into this
so it removed june for some reason the
last
yeah
so
i think
yeah i would i would take that
attempting to connect address out
and make sure that it's not negative one
yeah i like that
just
if
if uh
index greater than or equal to zero
like that and probably
i feel like i wonder if i should do the
same thing here
i think it would always be in here if
it's closing
we're gonna leave it
watch it crash
yeah
so
we start up
we try to connect to the known peers
none of them will be running right now
so nothing's gonna happen
yeah
and then
message received
so the message that we receive should be
this message handshake
yeah um
and then
well do you want to
i
i think you also have to parse that
message into
yeah
if you wanted to um but you want to just
create a bunch of nodes
and test it out
see what happens
yeah
because they should try to connect to
each other shouldn't they
um
yeah they should send some messages
around yeah okay so there's some helper
functions to run
to clone it
i'm in the node 1 folder so i actually
have to
back out here and then i go known clone
node
i might
do it twice so we have three so now we
have three
and look over here and split this up
and then now i gotta
go into each folder
cd node 2
arc
cd
node
3
and run
the thing
we've got problems
i know
attempting to connect a dress
dresses
um
so
you gotta go back you can't just copy
the code over to the different notes
which is probably the way to go
but you can also
use this uh
node delete nodes which will delete the
things there you go node
clone
on
tv node two
i would have tried running the first one
before
cleaning them again but
it's syntax error
what's here
cannot find name attempting to connect
attempting to connect
addresses
attempting to connect
addresses
that's a typo in the
boilerplate code attempt
i think i'll edit that
that is a problem
attempting it's everywhere oh no
attempting
attempt attempt
ding
okay we'll save it
run okay we
awesome nice catch
um
we are attempting to connect to 4003 we
got an error
because i have to let my captain i'm not
running all right
note index
oh it did it connected
attempting to connect to so this one
tried to connect to both this is 4002.
air connecting to 4003 that one's not
running connection to 4003
open connection open
connection
to
open
okay
so we had
a connection opened
4001 and then we received a message on
4001.
um
received a message
here and it's got
both addresses
and so
[Music]
um
i guess
const
data equals json.parse
data
um
not quite
whoops
dated too
not quite
date a string oh there we go
okay i don't like this anyway because
the field is data um
we'll go message
and then
um
message that oh what the heck was that
but again
i have a typo
just that data got for each
address
connect
let me see how many times you'll do this
okay
like is that all i need
that might be enough
all right well let's try it
so they should connect to each other i'm
gonna
re-close this one
um
delete my nodes
clone them
again
node
index will run this one so
it's running
why does it print closed there at the
end
connection closed
connection closed
um
so there it is your
um
air connecting so first it goes to error
and then it goes to close for some
reason
well
i suppose that makes sense because it
connects or does it
connect well attempts to connect right
it doesn't actually connect until it
gets a response i presume
yeah i don't know why it would close if
it hasn't
opened
no i don't know
oh well
number two um node index so now
we are in a loop oh
no that's fun
up
somebody help
crash it trash it
okay we're alive
um
that's quite funny
so
if address not equal my address and not
attempting to connect addresses that
includes address
socket.on close on air
let me see what it says over here
um
you should add what the heck happened i
can't even see my terminals to find out
um
so
i had a
server
listening
i started up the first one
and then i started up
the first one tried to connect but it
didn't make any connections because
there's nothing else to connect to the
second one opened
and connected to the first one
and sent the first one this message
its own address
yes just its own address
and so then the first one
tried to connect to the second one
which should assuming you want to not do
the connect if
it's already connected
so
yes you need another
yeah
yes i do that is the problem
perfect that's teamwork right there
yeah don't think there's anything wrong
with that
if connected it and
okay
i'm
doing this with my eyes closed okay
if
address not equal to my address and if
not
then just if not connected
it's okay
all right let's try it again
um
okay we've got several nodes
and
run that one
okay that looks
good
cd node two
index
okay okay i think that's good
so this one got a message
with the two addresses and then it
attempted to make a connection there and
it opened one
all right
let's see what happens here
um
cd
three
okay
oh that'll break
oh we've got a whole bunch running
four nodes running all connected to each
other and i think that should pass
well no infinite loops is a good sign
crossing my fingers i see a lot of x's
message
do i need to do more
here
on close on error send data
that really looks
good go ahead
well
i'm just thinking so the server
it's only connecting
when it receives a message
does the
so you have
on open you're sending something
don't you want to send from the server
the
connected addresses
not from the client
this kind of is the whole thing is the
server
you can call it a client and now that
makes
sense for typical websocket stuff
well that that it
the
um
so
when you say new websocket that that's a
websocket client
yeah when you say new web socket server
that's a
websocket server so
i'm thinking
when the server
receives a connection
they should send the server should send
here are all my connected addresses
you might be right
didn't read any of this hardly
um
oh i did read through it pretty good
if sorry
so when you connect to a server you
should send it a message with these
but
the server doesn't need to because
what you're basically doing
right now is
if you start up node 5
then
it's not connected to anything
but it's
whoever first it makes a handshake with
it's saying here are my connected
addresses
as opposed to
connecting and the server saying here's
everything i'm connected to
so note 5 would send it
it would start up it would connect to
this first one
and send it its own address
and the first one
would receive it
and then attempt to connect back to it
and then when the first one connects
back to five
it would then send
all the connected addresses
where five would
then then attempt to connect to two
three and four
maybe that's not the right way to go but
what is there anything in the console
that's
giving
reason for the failures
i'm doubtful
this is not
so that says it's crashing
that's throwing
um the tests pretty much just try to
make connections to all the different
things and see what the handshakes come
back is
yeah it's not reaching the assertions
which is why it's just an empty object
do you think
i'm i mean it seems like it seemed like
it was working they were all connected
to each other so it seemed like that
they
should have passed and that it was
working as it should have been right or
no
maybe i'm missing something
um
we'll start start node four up again
let me close
everything
oh
there we go
so node one
um
not quite
over
cd node one
node index
node two
started
attempted to connect to
one
and three
error on three
and one worked
yep
and then the message received is i am
connected
to one and two
oh yeah okay so it's it's my address and
connected addresses
yeah yeah
that should be right
yeah um i think that that makes sense
cd node
three
let's see what this one said
it gets a little busy here
yeah
um attempting to connect to one
one open
and then it sent me
all these
yep
attempting to connect to two
and the first one received these two
which seems right
yeah
attempting to connect to two
and it did open and then it received so
2 sent it back this
then stopped because it was already
connected to all those
message type handshake data
i see something
i see something
in there
i see something
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so i'm gonna
this time
i'm going to
copy
code
me
okay i think that looked great
tess i think
it's patina thing would show up in the
console though
nice
we got it
if i run the test again
there they go
well
how long did we spend on a typo
about the average time you usually spend
on a typo
awesome that's three down
so moving on to
the
fourth project
which is
building a web through client side
package for your d-app
and in this project we're going to be
building a client-side package that's in
the form of a class that can be used to
interact with a web3 provider which
would basically be your network for a
blockchain
we can see the files we have here
the
class is in this
index.js file that we need to build out
we can see an example of a provider here
which is basically just a rest api
consisting of some routes that you would
interact with in rpc calls
and
so
we should first cd into
the build a web 3 client side package
3.
and we have the boilerplate
in the index.js file
and we can see an example of the way
that this api that we're building out is
going to be used
in this example client
where we are importing the class
and we can see some methods on this api
such as set client address
init smart contract
[Music]
and we can see that basically the api
just uses this to interact with
uh the
smart contracts that we'll be building
out where we can call the methods
that might exist with a smart contract
and there's an example idl that we pass
into initsmart contract that we can
find
here and this is
very basic ideal which is
basically a schema of your smart
contract it tells you
in these instructions it's basically the
methods of the smart contract we have a
setclick
method and a getcontract account method
the args expected for the setclick
method is
one argument that is of type string
and there are no arguments to the get
contract account method
the user stories
that we will be completing
let's
just go for it so
we know that we will be
we need a method that is set client
address
and that takes in an address
and doesn't return anything and what
this method does is it sets the class
address property to the given address so
that's
the start address
to give an address
which means that we need to construct
our class
with some address that i'll set for null
okay we'll call that one down the next
method
is call
and it accepts an rpc call
object
and it returns a promise so we know that
this is asynchronous
and
what this does is makes a post to the
call smart contracts
route
on the ahref of the provider property
so
this class will have
a provider property
that will be equal to
something
and
we will want
to
make a fetch
to this route which
what we can do is
the provider
href
and it is to the call
in fact
and then we want this to be
first method
which means we will have a body and the
body of the post should be the rpc call
object literal and the address property
of the web3 class
so we need a body here
and let's just
create a body that is
the rpc call
and
the address
of the class
i remember when going through this that
i struggled with the
the url there that when you make that
call smart contract it doesn't need the
forward
right
slash
so
we do have a link down here to the
url api of
its basic javascript api that also
exists in node
and
if you play around with it a bit you
you'll kind of figure out that calling
atriff it always appends to the end
of the string the forward slash
i i suppose the smarter thing to do here
would be to
um
i know i know you would use the
path api to the path module and the join
method and you would join these two
paths together um
problem my head i can't think of how to
do that with the url api but i'm sure
there is a way
so
now we
need to
the call should return the result
property of the response
or throw an error if the response
contains an error
property so
what we need to do is get out
the response which is
s
and if response dot error
into throw
this will just throw a new error that is
that error
otherwise
we want to return response dot result
so that should be that method done
and now we need an init smart contract
method
so we can see this also
would there be a way to desire to
interrupt there'd be a way to just to
make sure it's working other than just
like running the tests
that's a good question um
so
it would be a bit difficult uh you would
need to get
the provider up and running so what you
can do is create a new terminal just
you don't need to create a new terminal
you can start the provider
by
saying node node provider dot js
leave
and we can see here what warp does is
it
starts the provider it deploys
the smart contract with just a test
smart contract
that is located in this package file
and then it starts listening on port 301
so i suppose we would need to set the
provider here
[Music]
and we could
manually do that with
new
url
http
localhost
v01
so from then we could actually just
write some tests ourselves so
if we wanted to
uh let's just do something simple
so we could set the client address here
and we could just make a thumb
and then we could console.log
e web3 dot
address
i think
if we did that
we can open ourselves a new
terminal here
and
we could
run this in node and it should work so
except it is a module but we'll see what
happens
node
there it is
so we have tested
that creating the class works it
has starts with an address of null and
the provider is this url
object and then we change the client
address from null to tom and we can see
we printed out there
if we wanted to do a test on the call
we could
and yeah say web3.call and we would need
to pass in an rpc call
uh what that would require
is
well we could look at it from the
provider's perspective
the
[Music]
call method in this case
makes supposed to call smart contract so
he has cool smart contract
it gets from the body an id method args
and address so if we wanted to we could
just add in
an id
0
args would be
let's leave it as an empty array
method
we'll probably just get this wrong and
we can say test
what else do we need
address so the address would be the web3
dot
address
you can pretend that that works
and this is an async method so let's
just get the response out of that
and console.log
e response
and we run our script again
and we get an error
which is very fun
where is this error in json.pass so
actually while we're debugging debugging
debugging
console.log the response here
and
we'll check why that is happening
this is the response it looks like it's
just the old average um http response
and so why is json.parts not working
probably because we need to use the
weight res.json method
and
let's not console.log that
okay so we get a response from the
server here which is smart contract with
id undefined not found
why is it saying id undefined not found
that is a very good question because we
have defined it as zero
but clearly that just doesn't exist and
we can see
here also in the provider it's it's
logging out those errors
um
so
let's clear that for now and we will
come back to it
that is a bit more involved than i would
hope it to be
you can see it it basically if you get
an idea of what going what's going on in
the background you need to provide a
running
and then you can just run the script
using node and it all works and fetch
works in the fetch api works in node
version
i think it's 17 and above so
18 is
officially released so that is what the
docker image is running on
i feel like that would help
it would have helped me when i was
playing with this is kind of a way to to
test it more
and see if it's working or not
other than just kind of writing the code
and hoping
now that that is a good point it's
probably something we can add on to this
in future prs uh to make it more
user-friendly and just a bit more a bit
clearer obviously i think once you've
gone through the practice projects and
you've learned a bit of content and you
understand rpc calls better as well as
you know having built out your own
provider it makes a lot of sense what is
happening here where the fetches are
going and what's being returned
but
until then we can definitely try and
make it better
so
if this in its smart contract what we
need to do here is we need to
take in the idl which is your
um your smart contract signature
and we need to
basically turn that into callable
methods
so we can start by we know we want to
return
the smart contracts methods
and that means we want an object
and we will want to
here's an example if we have an idl with
these instructions where we have these
different methods defined by the handles
get favorite number and set favorite
number
you can see that after we initialize the
smart contract it returns a smart
contract object
that has these properties the set
favorite number method
and sorry the get favorite number method
and the set figure number method
so what we will want to do
is
for each instruction
of the idl
loop over that and add the handle to the
smart contract
so we want to put in the instruction dot
handle
we need to set that equal to
a function because that's what the
instructions are they're just functions
and
in some of the cases the functions will
be asynchronous
they don't have to be but they can be so
we just add the async method there and
we know that there are some args that
this will accept but we don't know how
many
we've defined it as a function
now
what we need to do is
the callable method should return a
promise okay so that's
set here in async and it resolves the
result of the core method somewhere in
here we are calling the start
call
and we are returning it so
let's not call
except we are
waiting that because call is
is
and
from here
we need to construct the rpc call
so just as we did
down here when we passed in the
obviously call to the core method we are
wanting to
construct this out of
where am i
yep
we want an rpc call
we need an id
which actually
is inside before loop
and
even more so we need it to be
inside the function and we get from the
instruction
it's actually from
the idle itself it has a property id
passing the id of the smart contract so
that the
giver provider or
um in our case
more likely validator will be running
the actual code of the smart contract
needs to be able to find the smart
contract on the blockchain so we pass in
the id
and
what else did we need we needed
args and a method so the method
we
know is the instruction handle
and
the
aux is the argus that passed into the
parameter
of the function
and did we need anything else
so
the address is done by the call property
itself we actually didn't even need to
include that
um
it's not it's overwritten anyway
see when we wrote this out the body
added the address for us
so it's just the rpc call here and we
can pass the rpc call into
this one
now
what we need to do at the end of in a
smart contract is return this object
that we have just recreated created
okay
are you happy with that though
i think so
[Applause]
okay
well we are moving on to create this get
balance method if if you ran the test
would it would it pass those
or is there
we can try and run the tests definitely
it's always a good idea uh run the test
as often as you can
and hope things don't break
so we're on the tests and we are
failing absolutely everything
there are a lot of tests yes actually if
you're wanting more information you can
probably read the test text yourself
we can
look at why it's failing and it seems
that something is erroring out in our
code
i think
one of our
issues that i definitely know of
is when we are creating
our
web3 class
um yeah we need to actually pass in
and i'm pretty sure i had it written
here somewhere
yes
remember it
it's a initializer or something
yes
you get the address from that the
provider address from that
i never know where it is
um
i wonder if it's in the
castle
so
in here we need the provider
address and we just replaced this hard
coding that we did for our testing
better
and the wonder if changing that will
allow us to pass any of these tests
isn't it is it provider that
hr for url or something or is it just
provider
well the constructor just accepts a
string
okay and we turn that into our url
ourself
okay
and
we're still failing all of those so i
think one of the better things we can do
is finish out the api here
just so we don't get any crashes and we
will be defining a transfer method
that takes in
an object
and let's just say from to
amount so this is
all to transfer from one address to
another address a certain amount
and if we do that
see what
running the tests
does nothing
we can look into what is actually
happening by reading the
server output
so web 3 is not defined
which means we are not exporting this
well
we need to make sure
let's just comment about our tests for
now
okay there we go so our tests were
messing up
the output there i'm not exactly sure
why but we
we will leave it like that
so we are actually passing
first five here
we're exporting our class we are
so your web3 class should have a
provider property that is an instance of
url constructed from the initializer
argument that's what we've just done
here in the constructor
and we have the say client address
defined correctly
there is an asynchronous method
with the handle call we have done that
and call makes a post to
this route
so what we are not doing is post
call smart contract should have a body
including the json stringified version
of the rpc object literal so we are not
stringifying our body
it's always something to remember
okay
and let's keep going so
we need a content type header set to
application
json
so that would be in the headers
and we need
[Music]
never remember if this actually needs to
be capitalized in a certain way so we'll
just try it out
and we are sending through json
it looks like the it's capitalized in
the
text and the instructions
so if you read your instructions
correctly
then you will probably have a better
time passing the test thank you tom
so the request should have a body
including the
json stringified version of address we
are doing that yes he has address
the core method should return a promise
yes we are doing that if the response
contains error throw yes oh we are
passing that excellent
we're passing all of these
and then down here we are failing
one of the internal tests where it's
actually testing out the api
so if we go to 17
in the console we can probably see why
and these used to be in
numerical order but for some reason they
are no longer and it seems that it's
just crashing there so
let's run the tests and see if we're
passing any more
yes we are
almost there
and now we need to actually to find out
the get balance api
so we need to make a post this is more
of the same that we did in the call so
i'm actually just going to copy paste
this
we are
matt this is fine so
instead of a fetch to call smart
contract we are making a fetch
to
get balance
and the get balance request should have
a body including the stringified version
of address so there's no obc call here
there is just address
and
we can see back in the function
definition
that address is optional
so
we need to fall back
to
well if the argument isn't passed in
here then we need to fall back
to the
classes address
and we also need content type here
excellent we've done that
balance method should return a promise
that resolves with the result
i think we are doing that resolves with
the result yes
and
if it contains an error throw that error
we are doing that
okay let's see if we're passing those
tests
okay
and we are so now we need to just do
transfer and i think that is again more
of the same
except now instead of address
we need
the from to an amount in the body and we
need to json stringify this so
if we change
body to
just from to
an amount
we didn't need to destructure it here
but that's fine we'll leave it
and instead of get balance we are
changing this too
okay
let's run with this
and i wonder if that's it
no what are we failing
if the response body contains an error
property transfer throws an error with
the value of the error property
are we not doing that
looks like it
well then let's go to the console and
see what
expected missing required fields
to equal missing required fields from no
that's you're not destructuring
correctly or something there in that
body i think body equals from 21 oh that
looks right
so in this case we're saying from is
undefined
but it's expected from to be null
expected from to be null so actually i
wonder
what we want from to be is
our address
so you know what we should probably
actually read the user stories
i wonder if
it says the body should be jason's
string of my body okay you are doing
that
i suspect we need to actually say from
and this needs to be
either from yeah
or this dot
address
and that something's just wrong there
but yeah
that might work
yeah we might need to make that actually
clear in the
tests and things there we go okay
so we passed all of those
that was quite involved but got there in
the end
and
yeah
okay on to the
final integrated project
and this one is
build a smart contract in rust
so for this project
we need to create and deploy a smart
contract using rust
that keeps track of how many users have
clicked a button
very fun
and
our boilerplate starts us with a rust
library consisting of unit tests and
integration tests that we are expected
to pass
so let's get that up here
nice so we can see where we need to edit
our code and these are the unit tests
the integration tests are in the tests
directory
we can see those here
if we ever need to actually look at
those
so
boilerplate already contains the
necessary crates to complete the user
stories
but we need to import them into the code
and you will be required to define
structs and functions matching those
used in the tests
and we should only need to work in this
lib.rs file
so actually let's just cd into that
directory cd into bold
a yeah what are we smart
american rust
and
we might as well just run cargo test
lub to get this all going
that seems to working well
and here are the user stories
not too many
some useful resources about wasm and
rust in general
and some tips
okay
so let's get started
our smart contract uses wesenpac to
compile the rust code to javascript for
node.js um we already have wesempac
installed
so that is fine and we'll need to build
our smart contract data using it
the smart contract exports an initialize
function that returns this funny result
so we will need to export using the
public keyword to make the function
public and it is a function and we want
to initialize it
and this function takes no arguments
and it returns this
new result
public function initialize
with an s
okay so we are returning that result and
what we can do for now is just say okay
something
and i think
you see here in the user story it's this
function returns a context wrapped in a
js value
whatever that means um
this will probably help us
wrap a value image s value using
the from survey
implementation on js valley but for now
i will just continue with the api and
build out
ob functions so we also need to export a
setclick method
that accepts a js value with the context
type
okay so we need some sort of
context type in there but it's a js
value it's not context
because it is coming from the javascript
interface
and we are returning again the results
and what does this so this
function also accepts a string as the
second argument so we need to remember
that
and
which is the address of the user who
clicked the button so
and strings across
rust and javascript are
relatively similar in that they're just
strings
so we need
and i keep forgetting the fn keyword
get contract account it returns it
accepts a js value with context type so
we can just context
this value
and return
anything
okay
and this function returns an account
wrapped in a js value again something
that we may not know what means so let's
just add some
use to this
i enjoy doing that because we can run
the tests probably from here
what is this this is just like a little
rust
filler function that stops it stops it
from crashing or something
pretty much exactly that yeah so
normally if you have a um a linter going
with this as well
then
it prevents the linter from saying
hey you have unused stuff and hey
you know you say you're returning this
but you're not actually returning
anything so
i find the to do macro quite useful um
but i remember that i actually need to
import resin bind in and we can use the
prelude to get
all of that fun stuff that we've used
our js value in jsera and
yeah let's run the tests with this and
just see if we pass any of the
integration tests but it looks like we
erroring out because of this
so when in doubt
to do
i guess so
so we are still not compiling because we
need to actually define the account
and context structs
which we have definitions for over here
so
your library should export a struct
named account
so let's just do that yeah so struct
account
and it has the following fields total
clicks
and that is a u64
as well as clickers which is a
vector of strings and these will these
strings will be the addresses
of the clickers
other than that we need
context
and that has
a base account field
which is an
account easy
and i think we need to make these public
vector that's just an array or what
a vector it's yes it's it's a list
but it's
it it's pretty much an array but more
specifically it's dynamically allocated
so you don't have to
know the the size of it beforehand
sounds good
okay let's see if that makes the
compiler happy enough no it does not why
ah okay so we need
to do some more imports
in order for us to
what's the word crossover between the
javascript and the rust
or in this case wasm
interface we actually need to
serialize and deserialize
the structures that we have so we are
going to import d serialize and
serialize
and then from there we need to annotate
our functions
that
we implement the
we derive the traits for them so we can
use
the attribute
and derive serialize and be serialized
for both of these
okay i wonder if that is enough
one day we will pass these tests
okay it looks like i actually need to
spell correctly
okay so we we are passing something so
it's useful to know
we have here
some unused variables and
we are passing all
seven
unit tests
excellent so let's move on to just
do the integration tests
and that is wesmpac test
firefox headless
and you can run this in the browser
but
it just outputs the exact same
information that goes in the terminal
here so you might as well
run it headless
and while that's going we can see what
else we need to do here
so at some point we need to deploy the
package using node node
deploy.js so using the script
and we need to pass in the path to our
package directory
and we should run
node node smart contract
passing in a contract id
set click and clicker name to add at
least three clickers to the contract
okay we'll get to that later right now
it looks like we just have a bunch of
wasm errors probably because we are not
annotating our functions that we're
exporting
as
something for asm2
and maybe now we can actually get
somewhere with these tests
although we're technically still not
returning anything so where's them will
complain
we can
for some more of these user stories
so this function returns a context
wrapped in ajs value so we need to
create a context here is our context
so what we can do is just say let
context equal
context and this has a base account
which
value is account
and we need to start this with some same
numbers i would assume so we can do
little clicks zero no one has clicked
initially
or when we initialize the contract node
will have clicked
and for clickers
we will do an empty vector
that looks about right
except
we now need to wrap that
in a js value so
we go back down here to the tips we can
see
this value
has the from survey implementation
and we can pass in
a context
with our context
um and we want a result out of this so
we just need to
say okay
i'll
i don't have a letter for this but i
remember that from certainly expects a
reference to the context so we just need
to
little hamburgers handy
is that like a
is it like a return then it says okay
it's the return
so
in rust we have implicit and explicit
returns and basically if you leave out
the semicolon then it's an implicit
return
this is
standard
uh basically if there's no
ambiguation as to
where you're returning in your in this
case your functions then
you implicitly return but if there is
ambiguation maybe you have some other
if something then you'd it's better to
explicitly say hey i could actually
return from
location
but okay you're just wrapping
something
into a result
so
it's
it's just a type here we're saying
that our type returns and in this case
this case we're returning okay if for
some reason this initialize
uh some had some other logic and
infinite going as we expected
so in this case then we could instead of
wrapping it in okay we would wrap it in
error
and
you know we might want to do this but in
this case because the function is so
simple there's not actually anything
going on in here that wouldn't
fail during
compile time
there's no reason to have an error
variant of the result
so let's move on to something slightly
more complex the
set click function
are we doing with this
we are
well i suppose we need to find out by
um fulfilling the user stories in the
integration tests there we go so if i go
we know we want to return
the
context so let's just do the same thing
as above let's
do that
over
and we're not doing anything here but at
least this will compile
and in here we need to return the
account
you can see
that the get contract account function
it returns an account wrapped in the js
value now the account is inside the
context
so
we actually need to access the base
account
field
and we can say let account
or in this case
yup netaccount equal to
we'd actually first need to get the
context out so
i think
we define context and say that this is
of type context
and then we can
[Music]
use context dot
day so into sur day is
derived implemented full context
on a js value because we have explicitly
derived it as part of the
i always forget if it's serialization or
deserialization when you're moving this
way
um
but anyway and we are just using this
operator to propagate the error out into
a result if interstellar day fails to
derive it
ah sorry to deterioraze it
and then we need the account so let
account equal to
context dot base account
and we want to
wrap that js
value from
survey
and pass a reference to the account
let's see if
that allows the tests to run
no
and it's because from surday
returns
a result
so we need to unwrap that and we can
just
okay so
unwrapping all of these
from survey calls that's not how you
underwrite
we can
see if that
tests to run
no because we
have something that requires sized
context
serialize is not implemented for js
value
we are not trying to
where are we over here
this is an interesting error
um
i think one of the things we need to do
is in order to get the
account out we are actually just taking
a reference
and that might be all we need here
okay
that wasn't it
okay where's the error line 30 okay
okay so we've said this and no so we
need to let context equal
text equal to
context
so they
that's what it wanted
maybe okay so it's running tests
we passed four nice
we passed
another eight and then we failed some so
let's look at this we are
it's a lot of output here
but we can see that other than the
warnings we passed the four tests
result
to do with the initialize
function so the initialized integration
tests we're passing those
he said click we are passing
all of those which is surprising
oh no
we are failing this one
so it needs to push clicker and
increment total clicks
so
what we need to do is we need the
account out of this account equal to
you want to mutate this because we need
to increment the
clickers context dot
you want base account
and
then we need the account dot total
clicks
it equals one that's
plus equals one
and we need to push accounts dot
clickers
push
the address
so
that should be all we need there
and
now let's see if we pass any more tests
with that
you can't borrow this as mutable because
we didn't
declare it as mutable
that's why we did that there it is
shouldn't need that
okay
some more tests passing initialize
past all of those tests
set click
we increment it and we push it
okay so what are we fading
nothing
is that all we needed
well let's find out by running the test
here
okay so we passed the unit tests there
passed initialized integration tests set
click integration tests
get contract account integration tests
but we have not yet deployed our smart
contract
so
let's do that by running node
node deploy.js
and the path to our package directory
okay so we need a package directory
how do we do that we need to build it
first
so we need wax and pack
and
we have any more information about that
build your smart contract with node.js
as the target so
we need to wasn't back build
and to pass in node.js as the target
and
click return
this doesn't crash
okay something's happened it says that
your wasm package is ready to publish
at this location
so
if we just double check yes the package
is there
what we
then need to do
is just run that node node deploy
face and the path to the package is
uh just
it's just packaged
i think
okay we hit that and we get a bunch of
errors
maybe
we need to
[Music]
point it to the file
we can drop directly oh yes
oh a
smart contract in rust dot
yes
okay
that's done something
um let's what would the wasm file be the
contract
so
the fun thing about bull building the
package like this using wasm
using
ryzen pack
is that
because we are interfacing with the
javascript api
uh you can see with the js value here
we
need more information than just the wasm
we need
to do a whole bunch of memory
allocation and stuff
and that's done in javascript so that
when we import the package
it's
we can import it as javascript and the
javascript code then
uses
whatever wasm webassembly
um module in order to import the
instance here
and then re-export it you can do this
manually
but as you can see there's actually
quite a lot of stuff that you still need
so
and that's only because we're
interfacing with the javascript okay if
we weren't then we could just
run and use the dot wasm as
your yield average by
byte code
um so we've deployed that if we run the
test we pass that it's deployed
and you should add at least three
different clickers to your contract
state so this we need to
run this command to add at least three
clicks to the contract so let's do that
node node
smart contract.js the contract id we can
see here that the smart contract
deployed with id0
so let's add zero
and we want to set clicks
so we pass in the name of the function
which is cyclic and the clicker name
let's add tom
and i think what we can do is we can
view our blockchain
in
node
data blockchain
so we have here clickers dom nice
we can add another clicker let's add
myself
that done that's mind another block and
the clickers are now turtle clicks two
and clickers tom
and then let's add
a mud
another block
so
that
should be it
yes excellent